what a man of the Nights Watch doing in
a wildling camp my name is Jon Snow your
grace and thats dark sun this is a world
where bloodlines mean everything and
particularly for Stannis I mean whose
whole claim on the throne is based on
the fact that he is the rightful heir he
is the he is the true blood relation to
Robert breath in his older brother and
now he's meeting the young man who
wallah bastard is still descended from
Ned Stark and Ned was the one who
informed Stannis about his rightful
claim to the throne and so Stannis has a
lot of respect for the memory of Ned and
Sega's respect for Ned's family Stannis
is a person who takes obligations very
seriously and he has a debt to to Ned
Stark and Ned Stark died for Stannis's
birthright and I think help never forget
that and it definitely factors into his
decision to take John seriously we're
right there in front of you and you
didn't see us one look in the past 20
years one real look at your own children
and you would have known known what it's
a huge gamble on Cersei's part you need
to be steely and tough as hell to pull a
move like this on a person like Tywin
she goes up against him and she wins and
she wins with the one thing that she
holds over him which is his family
legacy she has a piece of information
that could destroy the most important
thing in the world to him the thing that
he's worked on his in his entire life
and I think the Tywin looks in her eyes
and when she tells him the truth he
realizes that she is someone who will do
exactly what she claims she'll do she's
very much her father's daughter in that
way
ruling is about maintaining order and
creating an environment for your people
that is safe and her dragons which were
such an asset in scaring the [ __ ] out of
everybody and making people throw down
their swords and run in the other
direction when she would come knocking
as a conqueror they're becoming a
liability that she can't afford anymore
it's one thing to be killing people's
goats and you can pay off a goat herder
for his goats you can't pay off a goat
herder for his children so she realizes
that she has to put the interests of her
people ahead of her dragon who are the
only real children she's ever going to
have
you are I ass dog Arya's really
impressed by her up until the moment
with brianne figures out who she is and
then our he gets really suspicious
because her travels over the last few
years have taught her to be quite
suspicious of strangers even strangers
who might appear friendly at first and
the fact that Brianne MIT sir
association with Jaime Lannister and as
the hound points out brianne's carrying
a Lannister sword you know re has no
idea that's the Valyrian steel that was
melted down from ice it's just she knows
it's Lannister gold because the the
hounds as it is and bran doesn't deny it
so all the Sun this woman who are you it
was quite taken with seems to be an
agent of the Lannisters and Aria doesn't
want any part of her brianne's really
caught unawares here I don't know if
she's thinking too far into the future
about what she's going to do with this
little girl once she gets her hands on
her but I think that right now her sole
concern is saving this girl from The
Hound she obviously doesn't believe that
the Hound is protecting REO somewhat
tragically because by the time we get to
this point in the story the Hound is
protecting area when he says he's
looking after her by the time he says
that he actually means it go on
do it
do it aria is in some ways the product
of this education were the hounds you
know telling her you're very soft and
you've always been soft and if you're
gonna stay soft you're not going to
survive and look at all your soft stark
relatives who died for being
soft-hearted or whatever and Aria is not
anymore you know she's become quite
tough and as much as there's been a
growing you know closeness between her
and the Hound at some points in the
season she's never forgotten what the
Hound is done and hand was on her list
and so the how now wants something very
badly from her and she's not going to
give it to you know and and it's kind of
a brutal moment because you kind of so
want Aria did give him mercy you know
just to be kind of sweet there but that
sweetness is gone if it was ever there
and partly the reason for that is
because of the Hound himself and she
gets her revenge finally for the murder
of her friend
Tyrion definitely has impulsive
tendencies especially when it comes to
his father at why I think he just thinks
about what kind of a father Tywin has
been to him and the fact that Tywin was
willing to have him executed for
something that he knows Tywin knows he
didn't do think it at the end of the day
he just decided it was time for Tywin to
be called to task for the way he behaved
towards his son for the past 40 odd
years
Tyrion is coming to deal with his father
and had no idea he was going to run into
Shea and it's heartbreaking for him
especially hearing her say my lion which
was always what whatcha call Kurian and
hearing it and realizing it's meant for
Tywin I Tyrion is a shock and and kind
of the final betrayal that just makes
Tyrion snap in this moment is horrible
as everything has been that's in a way
the most horrible thing he could
possibly see because she wasn't a [ __ ]
by the time they have become committed
to each other she's no longer a [ __ ]
when he tell when he calls her a [ __ ]
it's not that he believes this is what
she is is what he desperately needs to
tell her to save her life in his mind
and ironically he's ended up turning her
into that very thing that she was was
running from so the fact that she would
betray him with his father in that way I
just think something breaks in him it's
kind of the tragedy of these two people
who genuinely loved each other and who
both felt betrayed by one another and
end up trying to kill each other
to him
but found the crossbow you know one of
the great things about Thailand one the
reasons he is so good at what he does is
he's the master poker player and part of
that means never showing shock and if
you're gonna be the master the situation
you can't didn't MIT that you are done
by the turn of events and so I think
he's definitely surprised but but Tywin
is Tywin and he and he very quickly
tries to manipulate the situation again
and tell Carrie and I was never going to
let them execute you you're my son and I
think he's quite convinced that he'll be
able to talk his way out of this one in
this game that some of the characters
are playing no one's played it better
than Tywin and he doesn't believe that
this can be the end it's not going to
end like this Tywin Laster does not die
sitting on the toilet you know who
murdered by his own son he's kind of
shocked right up until the moment the
first ball hits him and then even more
shocked because he can't believe that
this is how it's going to end it's all
of Tywin shortcomings as a person and a
father coming together in a perfect
storm in this moment to fatal affect his
whole seasons about learning hard
lessons from your ruthless elders and
Tyrion learned that lesson this is a man
who's been trying to eliminate him
really from the time he was born and
Tyrion gets his revenge
what have you done
you